today's one minute monday is be prepared
whatever big goal you have for yourself
whatever big dream you've set out there
you want to understand what are the
steps it's going to take to get there
and be prepared not just for the one
step ahead of you but the next three
four five steps ahead because when
opportunity comes you want to be ready
to attack where most entrepreneurs are
so reactionary that the opportunities
are just flying by their heads let me
give you a quick example i have a client
who wanted me to come and speak at an
event and was asking me about my
my platform and my reach and how it
could help market as well and within
five minutes i had emailed back a full
nicely laid out pdf document with how i
compare my website and my newsletter and
my social media reach and my radio show
and my videos everything all in one
simple easy to understand document and
it was prepared to attack right away
because i already had that document
written what was her response she wrote
into me saying perfect i knew you'd have
something thanks a lot so on top of
being prepared and having a document
ready so i could attack that opportunity
i've also created the sense of being
prepared in my clients eyes and who do
you think they want to work with people
who prepared
saying i knew you'd have something or
people who are unprepared
so be prepared not just for this one
step ahead of you but for the next three
four five steps ahead so when
opportunity strikes you are ready to
attack
believe